hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that today will tear a
universe in upon itself as two of the
most acclaimed TV shows of this or any
Millennium waged Mortal Combat against
one another
it's an all-out anti-hero assault as
Breaking Bad takes on its little brother
Better Call Saul although since Better
Call Saul in its six seasons act as a
prequel to The Five Seasons from
Breaking Bad maybe it's the older
brother but anyway Jimmy McGill is a
little brother so you know what it
doesn't matter all that concerns us is
which show will take the crown as the
best in the Walt sullivers I actually
like the way that sounds
in one corner you have Breaking Bad the
show that debuted in 2008 and kept
building a steady audience as we all
realized that show with the dad from
Malcolm in the Middle is really good
well this all sounds pretty serious by
the end of its run we could forgive
Brian Cranston for accusing Jerry of
being an anti-dentite on Seinfeld
in the other corner it's Better Call
Saul the follow-up before the events of
Breaking Bad it has big shoes to fill
but one of the guys from Mr show led the
way and ended up being so good will
forgive Bob Odenkirk for that one time
he pretended to be Kevin Costner you are
not Kevin Costner
I was last night and since I'll be
judging the merits of these two Nair do
Wells who we still somehow end up
rooting for let's also give a nod to
Tony Soprano whose devilish ways paved
the road for shows like Breaking Bad and
better call Salt of room through
Breaking Bad actually played The
Sopranos in a previous episode of this
show versus who won no spoilers here I'm
already gonna give away some plot points
and character offings and bad and Saul
but I promise you you're in the clear if
you never saw The Sopranos and how that
show end
very funny guys
good one here's how we'll determine a
win round one ratings round two Tomato
Meter slash audio score round three
iconic kyramids round four the love you
take and then we'll do a Wild Card round
that weld hopes will involve meth making
magic while Jimmy will be banking on who
can pull off the zany or Khan and no I'm
not sure that cameraman is a real word
so if you're employed by Merriam-Webster
just wait until round three when all
will be revealed I myself am more
open-minded so many wonderful
performances intense scenes and
Cliffhangers emerge from these two shows
not to mention all the awards fan
adoration and online Rumor Mill churning
but only one will take the victory today
so no more white treading for me Mark
Ellis the time is nigh and though I'm
not a warrior I will be the judge and
jury on the show it's 99 pure it's
versus it's right here let's get it on
here's Johnny
round one ratings sure raw fans are
breaking bad and Better Call Saul Now
heck we won't shut up about them until
every one of our friends and family is
convinced that they need to see it right
now unless they're busy finishing the
wire
[Music]
but this round will measure how many of
us were actually on board for the ride
itself while it was happening shouting
from the rooftops of our RVs why isn't
anyone else watching this Better Call
Saul held a built-in Advantage given
that it arrived after breaking bad so I
already knew the Mystique of its big bro
even if we weren't sure how it was going
to go couldn't live up to the Legacy was
this a good idea at all and so of course
we tuned into that first saw episode
just to get a feel for what our scene
stealing lawyer was all about so it
should come as no surprise that almost 7
million people tuned in to see a dreary
black and white Cinnabon at the outset
of better call Saul's debut that would
end up being the most amount of views
that any single saw episode would muster
but make no mistake the vast majority of
us were intrigued and made this show
appointment viewing season one would go
on to average 3.2 million folks watching
per week and that also ranks as the high
bar for the franchise you're bigger than
that Breaking Bad had some pressure on
its debut as well uh we didn't know much
about it and the trailers did show Brian
Cranston stumbling around the desert in
his tidy whities as appealing as that
image may have been to you and me season
one of Breaking Bad averaged 1.2 million
viewers which is the low bar for that
series and that inaugural runs fifth
episode pulled in the lowest amount of
Watchers for either show at just under a
million the bottom line is most of us
missed the first boat when it comes to
the white family what the hell is wrong
with you then Word of Mouth started
trickling in and Breaking Bad began a
gradual rise in prominence and an
increase in seasonal viewers kicked in
the second year A bad averaged 1.3
million viewers then season three
notched 1.5 million and you're starting
to see the pattern the good news for
Saul is that by its season three it's
still averaged more gawkers per week
than its predecessor Goodman show
claimed 1.6 million sets of eyeballs but
also pointed to a downward spiral of
viewers from one season to the next
season four hauled in 1.5 million season
5 gathered 1.3 million and the final
season of Saul averaged the exact exact
same number of viewers per week as did
the first season of Breaking Bad 1.2
million claiming the better call Saul's
number skewed down partly because of the
streaming options available to us buy it
sixth season here's a fun fact I still
have no idea if I have AMC plus I think
I do I must if I watch Saul on time but
it got a little tricky at the end didn't
it and I'm not sure the old Nielsen
boxes could keep up why should I be
penalized because of your sloppiness so
that being said Breaking Bad became one
of the first modern shows to have a
robust Second Life on a streaming
platform that being Netflix as millions
of us watched or re-watched the program
there but for this round the door is
open if Walter Jesse and Company can
kick it down with some impressive
numerals in their final bows it's
penultimate season drew a then best 1.8
million folks tuning in but when Van
Halen said jump season five obliged as
the last run of Breaking Bad had an
average of 4.3 million viewers complete
with 10.2 million of us watching that
last episode I liked it overall bad
edges out Saul in total averages as well
Gathering 2 million against 1.9 million
and if that feels like it's a little too
close to call then let's let El Camino
break the tie and I am coming for every
goddamn one of you the Breaking Bad
follow-up grabbed 25 million watches in
its first week on Netflix and what
promises to be a harbinger of scraps to
come today Breaking Bad edges out a very
game opponent and Better Call Saul and
takes the first point of the day it's
white one McGill nothing much
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score now we get cooking with the round
that will be won by which chauffeured
better with the critics and the critical
masses in episodes passed on this show
the Tomato Meter can be a cruel mistress
that giveth and taketh away but these
aren't two ordinary shows we're dealing
with the only question in my mind is Who
Loved These shows more the reviewers or
the audience regardless I'm expecting a
high-end grocery store produce level of
freshness right here in this phase and
I'm assuming both shows will sport
grades that are good enough to get them
into an Ivy League school without
pretending to play a sport
you got me although Breaking Bad did
have to establish itself in the first
season with very little hype maybe
that's why it's Tomato Meter score for
season one is at 86 it's great by most
standards but it's looking up at better
call Saul's 97 for its rookie campaign
bad right at the ship in season two as
it tasted 97 then Seasons three and four
both pulled a Toy Story and are the
perfect 100 percent
oh
song Never quite got to perfectville
during its jog which is kind of on brand
for the character but consistency is the
key it hit 97 again in season two then
98 in three and tick home 99 for each of
its final three seasons it kept getting
better and better which is impressive
considering that you know it started off
with a freaking 97 if I ever got a 97 on
my first test of the semester I gotta be
honest I'm mailing it in the rest of the
way might not even show up I'm a
comedian what do I care it's all good
man
audiences also cared about both
television Ventures and they might have
been on the Breaking Bad wagon before
critics you see the audience score for
season one of Breaking Bad is 95 then we
climbed to 97 for two and three 99 for
season four and 98 for the closing run
making for an overall average of 97 on
this side of the patch Better Call Saul
Falls just short for its cumulative
score walking away with a 96 average for
All Seasons it's best with season five
at 97 its worst with season one at 95
which is how you get that average 96 is
the meat in the audience score sandwich
a memento
sorry what
pimento sandwich
but remember how El Camino kind of
nudged Breaking Bad over the Finish Line
in round one here in round two it's also
a factor but this time helping out
Better Call Saul the Tomato Meter has
the movie at 92 then the audience score
has a lower at 81 and again I have to
reiterate these are all great numbers
the leprechaun would kill to have a gold
resume like this and he actually has
but when we tally all the digits for the
Tomato Meter It's Better Call Saul that
Obi won's The High Ground with a 98
average to Breaking bad's 96 percent
which means Jimmy wins this day in court
and Better Call Saul takes the round
tying the ball game up at one to one sir
this is your last warning gotta be
kidding me round three iconic kyramids
and by now our returning fans have
probably figured out that caraments is a
clever amalgam of characters and moments
yep for the first time ever we're
tossing all the best roles in memorable
sequences into one giant Vitamix to see
which show is the cream that rises to
the top Better Call Saul has a good shot
despite its borrowing of so many
characters from breaking bad because we
got an embarrassment of riches in the
way of new people to cheer jeer and
watch with captivation like Kim wechsler
sometimes a morally sound lawyer other
times all too willing to go along with
one of her Beau Jimmy schemes Kim
rivaled that of the show's namesake were
their own story lines that left us
wanting more at the end of virtually
every episode Ray C horn perfectly Nails
the subtle rebellious tone of her
character whether it's matching wits
with Mesa Verde or in a corporate
boardroom or it's dining out with Jimmy
and cooking up some fun casual lies
Wexler feels like someone whose ultimate
intentions we can't quite pin down and
that makes for an enthralling watch week
after week
yeah my favorite moments for either Kim
or Bob odenkirk's Jimmy might just be
when they're chatting in the apartment
it could be movie night or it could be
when Jimmy returns after going missing
in the desert and narrowly emerging with
his life why well because we care about
this relationship individual characters
are great but Kim and Jimmy are proof
that the best TV ensembles become more
than just the sum of their individual
parts and of course the best is just
them saying effort and throwing beer
bottles off of their patio don't try
that at home kids use cans
Walter White is already married when we
meet him and we quickly become embedded
with his family unit that features Anna
Gunn as wife Skyler and RJ midi as his
son Walt Jr The Duo gradually see the
patriarch evolve from teacher to Miracle
cancer patient to meth Kingpin and
seeing the impact his choices have on
the family range from exciting to
heartbreaking sometimes together one of
the best interactions between hubby and
wife comes in the last season when they
chat on the phone even as Walter knows
the police are listening I built it's me
me alone nobody else you're right
Skyward Walt Jr give us a reason to Hope
Walter can somehow pull out of the
Spiral early on in the show once we
realize that he's gone beyond the point
of no return now just becomes a matter
of if they'll be complicit with that
lifestyle or Embrace who they've become
similarly Walton Jesse form an unlikely
Alliance that fascinates between teacher
and student buddies Frenemies bitter
axes the chances are no matter what
you're dealing with concerning a friend
or significant other Walton Jesse have
been the there before just maybe don't
rely on their solutions to help you out
because tens get pretty violent on the
ship
speaking of significant others the scene
and Breaking Bad that stands out amongst
the rest of the greatness is that moment
when we see Walt have one last chance to
break good and it involves Jesse's
girlfriend choking in her sleep Walt can
step in and save her but he does nothing
it's a sin of omission but a sin
nonetheless and a turning point for Mr
White from then on it's just a matter of
time before he is indeed the one who
knocks I am the one who knocks and say
we want about Jimmy and Walt the
Herobrine scams the breaking of laws the
watching someone die in their sleep but
they ain't even the evilest folks on
their own shows this is where fans of
both can embrace the sheer DNA of the
shows because seeing Breaking Bad
favorites like Gustavo Frank Hector
Salamanca and tuko appear in Better Call
Saul never felt like cheap fan service
instead we got so much more backstory
and drama to chew on and then Saul
blessed us with wallow Salamanca as
dangerous as he is charming really
how lucky for me and nacho who like many
other baddies on the show can say so
much with minimal dialogue I'm actually
rooting for nacho I'm a big fan of his
dad too despite the life path that he's
chose and fears he'll never escape from
family issues do pop up from time to
time in these programs and that was long
before or after Nacho's dad gave him one
more pep talk Michael McCain who I've
Loved ever since he was Mr Green in clue
[Music]
gives an acting master class as Jimmy's
older brother Chuck he suffers from
physical ailments that have some unique
cure possibilities but it's forced them
to become much more of a homebody and
even with regular visits from his little
bro the two can't seem to stay on the
same page for too long and at Chuck's
Old Law Firm Patrick fabian's Howard
Hamlin stands out as that guy you see at
the gym every morning even though you go
once a month he takes his Centrum he has
his shirts impeccably pressed his life
is regimented down to a t oh just like
that Halloween this is I don't know them
so when stuff starts breaking bad for
him Hamlin quickly finds himself in the
foreign world of chaos a land that Jimmy
thrives in some of the funniest moments
from the show involve McGill Goodman
messing with Howard everything from
smashing windshields descending ladies
of the evening to an afternoon business
lunch it's devious but Gabe appreciates
game and Jimmy has a talent Walter's
family issues get complicated not within
his own household as much as with you
know law enforcement his brother-in-law
Hank played by Dean Norris is on the
hunt for this blue meth genius and we're
riveted watching the Chase from our wide
lens of seeing the cat and the mouse one
of the all-time great moments in the
show takes place in a setting where we
all do our best thinking the bathroom
everyone needs a good read on the toilet
and when Hank visits Walter and Skyler
and excuses himself to powder his nose
there's some very interesting material
awaiting him but where Breaking Bad
might pull away here is the in-between
characters who just kind of show up but
still make an impact Badger skinny Pete
and extra points go to comedians Bill
Burr and Lavelle Crawford for gracing
the show with their touts ooh did we
talk about Mike yet no the linchpin of
both shows Mike's story gets deeper and
more heartbreaking in terms of family
with Better Call Saul but Breaking Bad
is where well it still pains me to say
it fun fact go back and watch the spoof
comedy classic airplane from 1980. Guess
who's in the air traffic control center
near Lloyd Bridges that's Jonathan Banks
Mike from the two shows today life it
lasts a long time kids so pace yourself
and don't do drugs
The Supporting Cast and even the day
players and Extras make these shows hum
but still the star attraction is the
respective leads Walter and Saul and
their choice is that sometimes benefit
them or their loved ones or their
employers or just the insatiable
appetite that they have to do something
wrong they succeed as characters because
they're no better than us not from a
moral standpoint anyway but they do each
have a particular genius and watching
that operate against their better
judgment is one of the many reasons that
we kept tuning in every week will the
angel or the demon win this time I am
the danger the devil is in the details
and even though Saul had an extra season
I find myself leaning towards Breaking
Bad for creating the vast majority of
these roles and for giving us an extra
nudge towards Better Call Saul when it
debuted Breaking Bad wins round three
and goes up two to one hey come on baby
come on yes come on
round four the love you take
Beatles fans May recognize that phrase
which expands to in the end the love you
take is equal to the love you make and
with shows that made us fall in love and
give us a whole lot to take away we now
focus on the respective endings of each
series and I will preface this round by
saying what should be obvious both shows
stuck The Landing you're goddamn right
neither of these shows ever pulled a
lost or a Dallas it was all a dream or
an Alf which I think just got canceled
right did he try to eat a studio
audience member oh no that was Gordy
oh uh-uh Breaking Bad and Better Call
Saul both got it right so who has the
edge and around all about going out on
the highest of notes even if it's
somewhat of a downer for some of our
characters well we did have some
information going into the finale of
Better Call Saul in that unlike Walter
we knew Saul was going to survive
somehow Jimmy maybe not
Kim Wexler was the Fate we were most
concerned about with that program for
breaking bad it was a raging debate as
the weeks became days became hours
before the finale as to what should and
will happen to Walt does he deserve to
pay the ultimate price for his misdeeds
is there any way that he can forge some
measure of redemption even as the Sans
were running out of The Hourglass or
maybe the better question was who's
going to get taken down with them so
much to chew on with both series Walter
and Jesse took turns leading the way
down a dark path but Walt stepped up as
gangster number one towards the end of
the show taking measures further and
risking greater than ever before maybe
it was a youth of Jesse that he still
could have had a different life one day
that made us feel like he was still
yearning to break good even as Walter
became more machine now than man twisted
and evil Better Call Saul had a very
different scenario at play events were
similarly coming to a head but we knew
the basement for Jimmy wouldn't be six
feet under instead it was a jail cell
where he's more of a prisoner inside his
own mind than body in The Slammer you
got nothing but time to recount and
recap and Monday Morning Quarterback the
decisions that you made that got you to
that point at the same time we're also
thinking about Kim wechsler she had
become such an engaging force in the
show complete with her own story lines
involving lawyering and her perspective
of who Jimmy is versus who he could be
if only he walked a straight and narrow
and now knowing that she's still out
there in the world juxtaposed with a
flash forwards of Jimmy's life after
Breaking Bad you just gotta wonder you
have no idea Walter didn't go to prison
he passed go collected 200 and advance
to the next life Walt died and in the
process gave the audience a meditation
on how one story should wrap up that
decisions have consequences and even if
your heart was initially in the right
place you can't ever go back to who you
were before we're fine okay death was an
option for Vince Gilligan and Company
when plotting the end for Mr White we
watched it all play out we understood
that it was just another point of no
return for a character who blew through
so many moral checkpoints on his five
season Journey but Jesse he got out
[ __ ] he drove that El Camino out of
Dodge and gave us something to think
about going forward what happens to this
dude we see some of his future in El
Camino and shout out to Robert Forster
for appearing in both that and Better
Call Saul as some of the last work in
his legendary career
I love that response time but when it
all comes down to it the irony for me is
that even though we ultimately knew that
Jimmy McGill would end up as an
ambulance chasing money launder
approving cheap suit embracing lawyer
and Breaking Bad we still had no idea
how the end of Better Call Saul would
play out even though it was Breaking Bad
that eat out a victory in the round
three cameraman stage it's the folks
that we met courtesy of the prequel show
that mattered the most in its finale
sure Jimmy's fate was reason alone to
watch but Kim wechsler acts as the
tiebreaker here I wanted to see what her
future might be or if there would be one
in all and even though Jesse Pinkman
made out with his life in a cool ride
and a sequel movie with his storyline I
still feel like Kim gave us the most
hope not necessarily for a future movie
with her although I think we'd all be
watching opening weekend right Netflix
you got us we're talking bird box
numbers here this is so exciting it's
Better Call Saul that did more for me by
the slightest thinnest skinniest pediest
of margins with its final bow and it
takes round four meaning we're all tied
up up at two to two
[Applause]
Wild Card round cultural Legacy it all
comes down to this which is cool and
we're braced for a dramatic ending on a
par with Breaking Bad or Better Call
Saul the only difference being I'm
pretty much in charge of this ending so
remember it's my opinion you're all
smarter than me and have probably done
less time in jail
how does one disseminate the legacy of
these two programs or really any TV show
well the first thing that comes to mind
is Awards those cool gold platinum
silver best participation in my case
trophies that signal you did the job
better than anyone else and deserve a
pizza party at Sal's by Victor in
Williamsburg Virginia is that too
specific of a reference
then let's expand it to the Emmy Awards
Better Call Saul has amassed an
impressive 46 nominations during its run
while Breaking Bad total 58 for its jog
my God that total includes 16 wins
including Outstanding Drama Series in
2013 and 2014. so we're competitive here
but remember how influential Breaking
Bad was picking up the Baton from The
Sopranos well then if you have an
influence it can Inspire other folks to
do something similar such as create
captivating TV shows that feature
everything from dragons to the Ozarks
now look I know George RR rode Game of
Thrones long before breaking bad but you
gotta think the show Runners looked at
the early seasons of bad and were like
they can do that without medieval sex
drugs and rock and roll we're gonna have
a great time on HBO all this is to say
Breaking Bad might have inspired more
competition for its prequel when it came
time to dish out the awards all told
Breaking Bad Trails Better Call Saul
when it comes to prominent award show
nominations
241-234 but Saul only has 40 wins to
bad's 151 victories and that's the only
time you're going to say 40 wins isn't a
lot that's really good you kids out
there you ever win 40 times in anything
give yourself a trophy and a pizza party
Rock Pizza now let's take a peek at the
all-time rankings next you see in sports
you have polls that will tell you where
a team is in the middle of their season
but in entertainment magazines and
online Outlets tend to save their
ratings until after the show has
completed its last dance cut down the
Nets and bid us adieu I do have a
feeling that Better Call Saul is going
to age like a fine Vino and climb up
some of these charts in the next decade
but it's still starting out pretty good
BuzzFeed has it rated as the eighth
greatest show ever ranker has it at
number 13 and Empire has it number 27.
again they're looking at every show ever
which begs the question did Mr show
appear in any of these lists it was
really funny y'all Bob and Dave for Life
how Breaking Bad do on these lists um
well we might have to sell our cow for
some magic beans plant them and then
climb the ensuing Beanstalk to get the
answer because it's really high up there
it's number three according to Rolling
Stone number two shout out to Hank on
the John on the Hollywood reporters list
and number one ever for Rancor stacker
and Empire again this is for like every
show ever cheers Martin Monday Night
Football Celebrity Death Match pop-up
video every show ever when we boil it
down distill it compress it and pound it
into pure blue powder form Breaking Bad
didn't walk so Better Call Saul could
run it sprinted for five superb seasons
and then Jimmy mcgillin company kept the
pace so what is the better achievement a
case could be litigated and I know a few
Warriors Kim's pro bono they'd Better
Call Saul had the tougher task you
almost never get a spin-off series it's
even close to the quality of the
original for every home run like Frasier
you have strikeouts like Joey which I
feel bad saying because it did last a
few seasons right and I like the
trebianis but it ain't friends and it's
almost never brought up when we talk
about the friends universe
but Breaking Bad had to make us care
about this Galaxy and not just the star
planet known as Walter White it had to
establish a treasure Trove of characters
and storylines that kept us invested our
heads on swivels and that was after it
had to accomplish the improbable and
stay on the air after viewership was
slow to come on board initially Better
Call Saul did a whole lot to entertain
us and keep the Breaking Bad flame
burning and additionally it started many
new Fires for us to look at but if The
Sopranos introduced an anti-hero as a
non-archy bunker serious dramatic take
then Breaking Bad took it to another
level in terms of cinematic television
and plot twists and turns we can still
drop episodes like the fly and
Ozymandias thanks Ryan Johnson in a
conversation and everyone knows what
we're talking about and they'll probably
gush alongside us I'm choosing between
two of my favorite kids here but I'm
going with the older one or
chronologically the younger one it's
Breaking Bad that takes the Wild Card
round thus winning the match
I won I love the idea of TV shows in the
same universe battling each other maybe
not friends versus Joey that might be a
little unfair but cheers versus Frasier
that's a good episode Monday versus
Sunday Night Football Alf versus Gordy's
home we gotta figure out a way to do
that one as for today a friendly
reminder with a Saul Goodman grin that
again it's all my opinion and it could
change with the Texas weather so now I
put the onus on you dear reviewer via
the Jessie to my wall and share your
take you can hit me up on social media
at Mark Ellis live I'm taping my next
stand-up special in LA on December 3rd
to get tickets at markellis.live and of
course stay tuned right here at Rotten
Tomatoes for all the latest in the world
movies TV prequels and sequels thanks
for watching versus I'm Mark Ellis and I
am the one who knocks
because most of my friends have kids now
and they freak out when you're in the
doorbell it's all good man